this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 25,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill on November 25th 2018
dr. Hashem qui announced via YouTube
that he had decided to push humankind
across a controversial threshold this
announcement was of course that his work
had resulted in the birth of twins who
had both been subject to genetic
engineering using CRISPR this was a
threshold widely considered to be
off-limits in 2015 two of the foremost
journals and research science and nature
both made similar statements stating
that modification of human germ cells
that is sperm and eggs should be avoided
the scientific community seemed to have
come to an agreement not to experiment
with this technology until we could
agree how and when to apply to humans
but dr. hurt gen cui has unceremoniously
dragged us across this line in the sand
whether we like it or not now more than
ever there is an urgent need to stop and
ask what the outcomes of this work are
for the individuals who are subject to
us and how the rest of society may be
affected to understand all this we're
going to need to understand how CRISPR
technology works and what the intrinsic
shortcomings of this technology are DNA
is made of nitrogen and carbon based
rings which formed four distinct
chemical codes adenine guanine cytosine
and thymine these codes form an easily
reproducible double-stranded molecule
which is read in groups of three called
codons which are contained within
structure is called genes these genes
are simply the Paris of the DNA that
code for the more structurally complex
proteins which in turn form the
biological machines and structures that
are required for all life on earth due
to DNA's ability to copy itself until
now the code in the DNA of all humans
can be traced faithfully to the first
cells on earth
dr. whose work changed all of this by
employing the use of CRISPR and caste 9
technology to purposely change the DNA
code in the two twins referred to as
Lula and Nana as its name suggests the
CRISPR caste 9 mythology is dependent on
two
parts crisper and cast night crisper is
a kind of repeating DNA structure that
was first discovered accidentally in
bacterial DNA by Japanese scientists
Yoshizumi Asano in 1987 for 17 years
following this discovery the exact
function of these DNA repeats went
undiscovered until it was identified as
the means by which bacteria identify and
protect themselves against invading
viral DNA it turned out these strange
DNA repeats actually came from viruses
bacteria have the ability to cut up
invading viral DNA store it in their own
DNA and then subsequently use it as a
guide system for the enzymes cast 9
which destroys the viral DNA sequence
should it invade again in the future in
order to do this cast 9 uses the stored
DNA to make something called the guide
RNA this guide RNA is usually coded for
by a CRISPR repeat and guides CRISPR to
DNA it should cut there are two
conditions for CRISPR is binding to its
target first caste 9 must bind to the
target sequence and a specific 3 code
variation in DNA which is called a pom
most poms can be recognized by caste 9
as they contain the code GG these
reoccurring patterns are targeted by a
bacterias caste 9 system as they
identify the DNA of invading viruses
this gives the bacteria an ability to
target and destroy the viral DNA however
in the last five years we've learned to
leverage this ability to direct cast
night with guide RNAs of our own design
to alter the genome of other organisms
the guide RNA binds to a parent of caste
9 called the alpha helical lobe in turn
another domain of caste 9 the nucleus
lobe binds to an e flanking part of the
DNA strands that matches with the guide
RNA causing the double helix structure
of the DNA to unwind this process is
facilitated by the proximity between the
DNA and the caste 9 complex and
electrostatic interactions that occur
between the RNA and DNA at this point
two specific domains of the nucleus lobe
cut the DNA although we're not fully
sure how this mechanism occurs
comparative studies suggest the most
likely way is that the two separate
parts of caste 9 are able to rip protons
from water molecules and in turn
weaponize a''s the deprotonated water
molecule to break the DNA apart this is
done at two sites in the DNA one which
Cleaves the DNA at the target site and
another which cleaves the DNA at a non
target site at this point a number of
things can happen depending on which
approach is needed cast 9 can be
modified to include a deaminase enzyme
which can target specific basis for
mutation leading to brand-new mutations
a process known as homology directed
repair can be used to insert new DNA at
the coding site or the targeted piece of
DNA can be simply cut out and removed if
it is deemed to be undesirable dr.
Hirsch Inc we opted for the later option
and simply cut a section of a gene
called ccr5 the section that was cut
corresponding to a mutation known as
Delta 32 that confers its owner with
protection to certain strands of HIV
doctor whose data seems to suggest he
may have artificially induced a mutation
similar to but not identical to the
Delta 32 mutation in these twins in
order to do this dr. hood had to first
optimize the gene editing protocol in
mice monkey and human cells the reason
for this is to make sure the protocol
has high specificity simply put that the
gene editing technique was editing the
target DNA and not some other sequence
this claim is of course key to the
validity of the experiment on edited
embryos can be thrown away after all but
for obvious reasons making on specific
alterations to a human's genetic code
would be a major red flag and dr. his
work raises major red flags for this
exact reason there check for specificity
of gene editing use parental genetics as
a reference point an inadequate approach
due to the fact that a parent's genetic
material is subject to a certain degree
of randomization every time a sperm or
egg is produced it's further complicated
by the fact that no two sperm or eggs
will be the same and that their
mythology did not account for the
possibility that larger sections of the
genetic code
could be deleted by their implementation
of the CRISPR caste 9 system further to
this from the data released so far we
can tell that the mutation induced in
the twins does not exactly mirror the
Delta 32 population that her is
attempting to induce in the twins
although the protein produced should in
theory largely mirror the naturally
occurring mutation we cannot tell that
for sure because it has not been tested
standard practice at this point is to
test these mutations in an animal model
in order to assess unexpected effects of
the experiment this is perhaps the most
troublesome part of this experiment Lulu
and Nana are test subjects for a genetic
mutation that we have not even taken the
time or care to test in animals
nonetheless the mutation was induced in
a total of 31 human embryos these
embryos were grown for a period of five
to eight days and the 19 that were
deemed normal were taken forward out of
these 19 embryos two were implanted in
the mother to give rise to the twins
these concerns over Lulu and Nana's
well-being are only one of a myriad of
issues perhaps most critically there was
no medical need for this treatment in
the first place it has been claimed that
the biological father of the twins is
HIV positive but given that the couple
used IVF and that there is no evidence
that HIV would be passed on from father
to child using this method of conception
the procedure was medically unnecessary
furthermore her claims to have induced
this mutation completely into at least
one of the twins to do this her and his
group would have had to check the DNA of
every cell in the growing plasticize a
group of cells that exists from days
five to nine post fertilization that
eventually becomes the embryo given that
they would have had to destroy the
plasticity to test all the cell's a
clear logistical problem exists in
trying to qualify the mutation exists in
all cells accordingly her and his group
only checked a number of cells from the
plasti cyst this means both twins might
have a condition called mosaic ism where
the deletion only occurs in a subset of
their cells this means that the
different cells in their body have
different DNA
in this context the effects of this
condition are completely unstudied
finally the gene that hurt took a mat
has also been reported to have a role in
learning a link between the activity of
the ccr5 gene product and the dampening
down of the brain's ability to form new
neural connections has been previously
described in mice models theoretically
there is a possibility that the induced
deletion could have a positive effect on
the twins ability to learn right now
there are far too many unknowns to make
an accurate prediction on what if any
effect this experiment will have on the
two twins and there is an even bigger
question about what effect the
announcement will have on the progress
of the field complicating this mess is
the fact that this study did not go in
front of an adequate EDX approval board
and the default Chinese laws prohibits
any kind of follow-up with twins because
of this we will likely never know what
will become of lulu and nana doctor who
has stated that he plans to publish the
work in a peer-reviewed journal but
given the fact that he has gone m.i.a
for almost two months now the scientific
community may never have an opportunity
to properly review and digest the impact
of his work so where do we go from here
there is no doubt that genetic
engineering is a valuable tool that can
potentially safely increase human
well-being and productivity it's not
unlikely that plunging into these
uncharted waters unaccounted and without
approval may have a chilling effect on
the proper utilization and development
of this technology perhaps until a
consensus on the way forward is
established this is a good thing
thankfully the World Health Organization
has stepped up to take a moderating role
in the process and are establishing a
working group to establish clear
guidelines we need these guidelines
because we stepped into a new era of
Medicine one where the genetic
modification of humans is not only a
possibility but an increasingly real
option humans have long sought to
improve themselves through technology
from the printing press to the Internet
these inventions exist to expand our
knowledge and inform us maybe one day
we'll be able to alter our genes to make
ourselves smarter but in the meantime
were
ready surrounded by tools for this like
watching educational videos on YouTube
are watching in-depth tutorials and
classes like these ones you'll find on
Skillshare Skillshare gives you the
perfect place to start learning with
over 25,000 classes in a huge range of
topics ranging from creative skills like
painting and music lessons to technical
skills like coding with professional and
understandable classes that follow a
clear learning curve you can dive in and
start learning how to do the work you
love a premium membership begins around
$10 a month for unlimited access to all
courses but the first 1,000 people to
sign up with this link will get their
first two months for free so ask
yourself right now what skill have you
been putting off learning or project
have you been dreaming of completing
what you aren't sure if you've the
skills to do it why not start right now
and sign up the skill share using the
link below to get your first two months
for free you have nothing to lose and a
valuable life skill to gain as usual
thanks for watching and thank you to all
my patreon supporters if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
Instagram Twitter discord server and
subreddit are below
[Music]